what's up brother
hello how are you scott evans from
access hollywood listen
so many people have described this show
as thoughtfully earnest
and hilarious i wonder for you now what
parts of ted lasso
are you carrying on in your life moving
forward
[Music]
uh the mustache currently um for sure
um but yeah i mean anything that's in
that show is something that i carried
with me up to the point of creating
that show and and and co-creating that
show and
co-writing that show and playing that
character so
you know that shows catching up with uh
myself and if anything leading leading
me
and my soul forward
so our next question goes to amanda
williams from
e-news hi jason
congrats on your win tonight
um you mentioned your son otis in your
speech
are your kids awake i'm curious what
their reaction to
your win is tonight and how you guys
will be celebrating
uh their reaction is uh completely
selfish because they're six and four
um and you know the way they'll want to
celebrate
is by having you know uh
cocoa pop cereal or cocoa puffs i
believe they have here in the uk
and it'll have nothing to do with me
because again they're six and four
they're
selfish little demons and i i can't
believe they're not gonna
give me any any respect
you know
thank you uh so the next question goes
to jeremy parsons from
people the show
hey there jason uh good to talk to you
congratulations
i um i i just gotta tell you a huge fan
of the show and it's been one of these
shows
everyone i talked to has caught on to it
sort of this slow burn developing this
huge fan
following and then watching the moment
that your name was called it feels like
you were maybe just as surprised as
everyone
are you surprised that it's getting this
kind of love at this point
and where can we get the hoodie
uh the i yeah no that was a genuine
surprise i
despite the accolade i'm not a good
enough actor to pretend
that well uh and um
uh and the and the hoodie i think you
asked you're cutting out a little bit is
forwardspace.com i think it's my
sister's uh
you know dance and workout place in new
york um
but i believe in the uh the product
because it is a nice hoodie uh as much
as the uh
you know the message the next question
is for heather brooker from knbc
hey jason congratulations we love the
show so much
um i have to ask you know ted is
always going after that win he wants to
win so bad so
what would ted lasso say about this big
win tonight
oh i i think uh ted's impression of this
win tonight
would be um
[Music]
that it was a little too singular for
his tastes but
uh but but it's still it's nice that the
show uh you know garnered any attention
through its nomination for for the show
and and and for
uh the acting thing but um you know
we're uh we're on to the next one
jason congratulations to you people have
such extraordinary
people have great affection for the show
what did you think and it's getting a
lot of attention
on social media of don cheadle's uh
wrap it up direction while you were
speaking
hey that's just kansas city love if
anybody's going to tell me to wrap it up
he knew i'd listen to him that's all
that is you know a lot of people don't
know that he's
an excellent stage manager as well as an
you know
american acting icon like that's that's
the guy's got chops you know
okay next question goes to cynthia
littleton from variety
hello jason hello jason what can you
tell us about season two
of ted lasso nothing
nothing what a waste of a question you
can't give us
anything not a hint not a tidbit
yes of course i could i know everything
but i'm not going to say a word
i'll get sued by apple i don't want that
heat
you don't want that heat i'm saving both
of us
i'm pretty sure you made history being
the first actor to win a globe in a
hoodie
does it mean more to um for that hoodie
to be representing something that uh
is so important to your sister and to
your family
uh i think you gotta look back at audrey
hepburn for an
uh funny face she also wore a hoodie
um no that's not true uh
but um yeah i i believe
i believe um
when people that you care about do
cool interesting things that you should
you know support them so uh this is no
different than that
i have a multitude of hoodies i could
have worn for a multitude of things i
believe and in support and uh
you know this one seemed the most
appropriate
you